Trump Ally Rudy Giuliani is a target of
a new lawsuit accusing him of sexual
assault harassment wage theft and other
misconduct and they're asking for 10
million dollars in Damages the woman who
filed the suit says she worked for the
former New York mayor for nearly two
years and claims that he offered her the
job quote as a pretext to develop a quid
pro quo sexual relationship Giuliani
spokesperson says he unequivocally
denies these allegations Elaine kejano
has more on this story
the wide-ranging lawsuit against Rudy
Giuliani was filed in a New York Court
Monday in it plaintiff Noel dunfee
claims Giuliani offered her a job in
January 2019 as his Director of Business
Development with a salary of a million
dollars a year but said he'd have to
defer her pay and keep her employment
secret until he finished divorce
proceedings with his now ex-wife over
the nearly two years that followed
dunfee claims Giuliani paid her almost
exclusively in cash made clear that
satisfying his sexual demands was an
absolute requirement of her employment
forced her to perform a variety of
sexual acts and breached their alleged
business agreement dunfee claims to have
recorded many of her interactions with
Giuliani including one where she says he
told her I've wanted you from the day I
interviewed you attorney Justin Kelton
represents her she alleges that on
several occasions she objected
uh clearly that he did not respect those
objections the lawsuit also alleges
Giuliani a personal attorney to then
president Trump told Dunphy Trump's team
would claim there was voter fraud if he
lost the 2020 election in another
instance Giuliani allegedly said he was
selling pardons for two million dollars
which he and president Trump would split
there has been no proof of voter fraud
in that election nor evidence that
Giuliani or the former president were
ever compensated for pardons during his
time in office CBS News has reached out
for comment from the former president
but has not heard back
in a statement a spokesperson for
Giuliani said he denies the allegations
and will pursue all available remedies
and counter claims in response Dunphy's
lawyer said in part that Giuliani quote
will have to answer to materials and
recorded statements that will be
presented at trial CBS News legal
analyst Ricky Clement the real evidence
in this case for this complaint to move
forward has to be in the recordings
because if it's not in the recordings it
does hit the line of being so over the
top
that you wonder if it's all true or if
none of it is true and that's going to
be the defendant's argument for CBS
mornings I'm Elaine quijano